-Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar nominated actress
you know from films like
"Pride & Prejudice" "Atonement,"
and "The Imitation Game."
She stars in "Colette"
which is in select theaters
September 21st.
Let's take a look.
-Madam Colette? What are
your impressions after tonight?
-My impressions?
I'm disgusted.
The people who threw things
tonight are cowards
and the only reason I didn't
get a footstool in the face
is because I dodged it.
-Let it go, Colette.
There were some gentlemen
who came for a fight.
We must ignore them and go on.
-So you intend to continue?
-Yes.
-No.
-Those people don't
frighten me at all.
Look. Am I trembling?
-Please welcome back to the show
Keira Knightley, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome back.
-Thank you very much!
-Congratulations on the film.
-Thank you.
-We had your co-star
Dominic West here yesterday.
-Yes, I heard.
-And he had --
he was talking --
he was lamenting that he has
a lot of facial hair
in this film and --
-Yeah.
-He said -- he basically said
that the kissing scenes
were very uncomfortable for him
and I could only imagine
they were equally,
if not more uncomfortable
for you.
-It was sort of like
kissing a walrus.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, not that I'd know
what that was like.
-As you imagine.
-As I imagine
kissing a walrus would be.
Yeah, I mean, it's amazing
because he's a very sexy man
and he's really not in the film.
-Yeah.
-At all in any way.
-And he had to wear fat suits
and everything.
-Fat suits and we were shooting
in 100-degree heat,
so he had a cooling system
where he plugged himself
into this little bag,
and it looked like
a colostomy bag.
-Yeah.
-The whole thing was -- yeah.
-There's, yeah, very little that
sounds sexy about any of this.
-Absolutely not sexy. No.
-This is a period piece.
And you've obviously have
done films like this before.
And I've heard you say you're
actually drawn to these roles
because the female parts of
these films tend to be better.
-I mean, for me, yes. Yeah.
No, they have been, you know,
I mean, I've desperately
tried to do modern-day pieces
but keep wanting me to play,
like, you know,
the supportive wife
or the supportive girlfriend.
And I think, I'm that at home.
I don't wanna do it at work,
as well.
-Yeah. That's a good call.
-Yeah.
-This is, because this is
a film very much about
a marriage,
and it is a unique one.
It's an open marriage.
-Yep.
-You date a woman in the film.
You date someone
who sort of doesn't
gender conform
one way or the other.
-Yeah.
-And would this character
that you play would probably
have approved of your prom.
You did not...
-Oh, yeah.
-...go with convention.
-No, I went with my best friend
who is a girl and also gay,
and we had to kiss
for our prom photo.
And they banned our photo.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Where would the photo
have gone?
-Well, you know how --
I don't know if it's the same
in America but you have, like,
a prom wall of all the pictures,
and then you can --
-Oh, so over the course
of the night,
people just put photos.
Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. All the rest.
And they said
it wasn't appropriate.
-Wow!
-For the wall. Yeah.
-Scandal.
-Scandal. At 16.
-That means in 50 years,
your life story
will be a period piece.
-Oh, I hope so.
-For someone else --
-With that prom night.
-Yeah.
-We were talking backstage,
your daughter is 3 years old.
-Yes, she is.
-Obviously --
Did she grow up here,
or did she grow up in England?
-Here -- no, wait a minute,
where am I?
-You're in New York.
-I'm in New York.
-Yeah.
-Thank you. No, in London.
-In London, okay, good.
-Yes, in London.
-So she -- despite this,
she had a reaction, an emotional
reaction to the election.
-She did. So she's never
slept very well.
-Uh-huh.
-And she was about 18 months old
on the night of the election,
and it was the first time
that she slept through.
But I being the mother,
woke up at 5:00 a.m. going,
"Oh, my gosh! She's dead!
She's dead!"
And I run upstairs,
and she's absolutely fine.
She's completely asleep.
I go back to bed.
My husband is then sitting up
in bed having checked the news,
and Trump has won and he says,
"Trump has won."
And I go, "Oh!"
And we're then very awake.
And, so,
we're watching the news,
and my daughter doesn't
wake up until 8:00 a.m.,
which is about when he is
giving his acceptance speech.
Then I bring her into the bed,
and we've now got the computer,
and she sort of looks at it
like this.
And then she rolls onto her back
and she goes, "Oh [bleep]"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-I mean,
out of the mouth of babes.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-It was one, you did not even
have to understand policy.
You just saw the image and --
-Yeah.
-Just like,
"This doesn't look right."
-Yeah, no, no. Yes.
-Is she foul mouthed usually?
-No, no. But actually
I'm now thinking about it.
She's only --
so that was the first time.
And now she's 3, and we were
just on this holiday in Italy.
And, you know, Italian roads
are very sort of small.
And my husband was driving, and
she was in the back of the car.
And we were in one
of those blind bends.
And, you know, suddenly
there's another car
that comes toward us,
and he slams on the brakes.
And there's silence.
And this little voice
from the back of the car goes,
"Daddy, is that when
you say [bleep]?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, I mean, the problem
is both times you go, "Yes."
-Yeah.
-You know? I mean -- yeah.
-I mean, she's been
incredibly judicious.
-Yes. I mean, perfect timing.
-Has not wasted a single one.
Yeah.
-No, no. And, yeah.
-Something that would be very --
no one would blame us
for dropping an "F" bomb
about is we support the same
soccer club, West Ham.
-We do.
-We talked about this.
-Yes.
-Football club.
-Yeah.
-And they're off to what
only can be described
as a dreadful start.
-I mean, a really,
really appalling start.
-Yeah. It's only four games,
but it's as bad as it could go.
-It couldn't get worse, yeah.
-Are you raising your daughter
to be a West Ham -- have you
put any thought into that?
-No. Okay, so before I got
married to my husband,
my husband is a Tottenham fan.
And Tottenham and West Ham
in England hate each other.
-Yes, both London teams, yes.
-Both London teams, and they
absolutely despise each other.
So we had an argument
about our future children
and whether they'd be Tottenham
Hotspurs fans or West Ham fans.
And so we played
"Paper, Scissors, Stone."
-Okay.
-To, you know, decide
who was going to be, which one,
and I lost.
So she is now a Tottenham fan.
-Oh, wow.
And she's not allowed to
watch the West Ham games,
which actually is kind of
a good thing --
-It's okay, yeah.
-Because Tottenham's doing
really well and West Ham
is doing horrifically.
-It turns out it's worked out.
Love that.
-I have accidentally given her
a great gift, yeah.
-I'm a big
American football fan.
My wife is not
an American football fan.
But our deal was
that I could raise our sons
as Steeler fans if we also
raised them as Jewish.
[ Laughter ]
-Cool.
-That was the tradeoff I got.
Yeah.
-That's a pretty good one.
-Yeah, it's not bad
as tradeoffs go.
[ Applause ]